[Music]
coming in hot there's another episode
thank you guys for joining us today this
episode is brought to you by we have a
couple new sponsors today firstly stitch
fix guys if you like fashion like me an
icon of fashion if you like fashion but
you feel like it's too intense to
shopping or deal with any of that stitch
fix does the hard work for you and it's
all online it is pretty much a personal
styling service and you can take you go
onto the website and you basically fill
out all these preferences I tried it
it's incredibly thorough and basically
you get paired with your own personal
stylist who's gonna send you clothes
that work for you and your style right
now get started at stitch fix that's STI
tch Fi XCOM slash Jenna Julianne you get
an extra 25% off on us also guys a new
sponsor as well honey book if you were a
freelancer of like a graphic design
nature or a photographer doing the
administrate and you know administration
work or the business side of things to
run your company or run your business is
always kind of the hard part and the not
desirable part well honey book is there
to help you with that it's an all-in-one
business management platform for
creative creative small businesses they
help with all sorts of tools that you
need we'll get into it later right now
go to honey book calm h o n ey b oh okay
calm and use code Jenna Julian to get
50% off your first year 50% also guys
this skim you know the skim is a the
wonderful newsletter that rolls up in
your DMS well sort of your inbox on your
email every single morning with all what
you need to know in the world the skin
is the skin is great and it'll help you
dominate your conversations at work
especially at the water cooler right now
go to the skin that's th e sk IMM comm
slash annejulien
and to your email click Subscribe and
you're done it's completely free also
you're entered to win a $250 Visa gift
card when you do that thank you
thank you sponsors welcome back how's it
goin oh my teeth yellow no a mine no am
I know you just we drank some turmeric
ginger shots
we're so la why is turmeric and ginger
LA just shots of of wellness fruits in
that city where you and I both adore it
so we didn't really have a shot I had
like half a cup of it I guys love it I'm
just joshing yeah I love it
ginger like makes me feel so good and
like I'd never use it for nausea until
you gave me some in Australia at one
time what's not no I just feel good I
feel like flush and ready I got energy
now I was tired I don't feel like I have
energy either more energy that I did
before I'm no it's just like it just
makes me feel good no I haven't you have
energy from ginger no I have energy from
the the tincture that we call not a
tincture it's just got a like a mixture
of juices it's juice of ginger turmeric
whoo I'm in an apple uh-huh and it just
makes me juiced up no pun intended
cuz it's literal juice anyways no your
teeth aren't orange from turmeric oh
mighty go no they're not what is this
podcast Julian this is the Julian
podcast all sorts of stuff what is this
though we're doing doing oh I had an
idea I had an idea that I would I don't
know what's going on I had an idea the
other day that I would get thrown into
the shark tank if you've ever watched
this show shark tank on ABC I believe
didn't and didn't and didn't drink I'm
gonna play it for me I can find out in
the evening how do what is going on so
if you've ever watched the show shark
tank basically you know it's a show
where people come in with their small
businesses their inventions their ideas
and they pitch it to a roomful of sharks
quote-unquote who are basically business
moguls investors very successful if
you're looking for money for an
change for stock in their company or
that kind of thing or they just they
want help to grow their business yeah so
like Mark Cuban
Mark Cuban vernier Daymond John creator
of the legendary Robert Herjavec who
literally never puts it offer on the
table ever and that's the tea Thank You
Barbara I'm sorry is also a queen love
her I love Lori Corcoran
I love Lori to so much and mr. wonderful
Kevin it's a good it's a good group of
people and then there's Robert one of
our favorite things to do when we're
watching chart is make fun of Robert
[ __ ] dope guys it was just so fun to
hate on is like oh you're gonna be out
know whose [ __ ] oh no [ __ ]
he never [ __ ] makes it often here's
the thing I would respect him or not
make fun of him more if he like every
single time someone pitched an idea he
was like no I'm out you know like I'm
not I'm not I'm not interested but
instead he has to like do this whole
charade where he's like oh can I try it
like I'm so proud of you of it I'm out
yeah it's like wait what like what every
single time he does that like acts so
excited he's the first one to demo a
product or to ask questions or to like
connect with them or traffic it or
whatever and then he's like many like
inserts himself while the others are
negotiating he's like oh um it's like an
excuse he's like he's broke or something
yeah I just think it's really funny that
even if he put if he does put an offer
on the table nobody picks him and like
he even put like a better offer out and
someone will take the worse off to not
get him to work with like Barbara's good
no actually hey Robert oh I'm sure he's
a great guy but it's just funny it's
like funny how it pay because they all
have their role you know it's like
Damon's the clothing guy right Laurie's
the QVC investor and then you have like
mr. wonderful who has the the thing in
his ear he's being the producer always
asking for and things along and yeah
he's also the one that will
just throw out an offer that has to do
with okay you give me $1 per unit you
sell in perpetuity I don't know any
stock whatever and then Mark Cuban I
feel like invest mostly in tech aura
like second food he does food - yeah
yeah but it's really funny because from
what I can remember the companies that
Robert is successfully invested in are
like Mensch on a bench which is like the
it's cute but it's completely seasonal
it's like a it's Elf on a shelf but for
Hanukkah it's man Johnny Bench so it's a
little stuffed man you wish man toy with
a with a book and then he also invested
in tipsy elves who used to be a sponsor
of our podcasts another short person
like what did he invested in the Mensch
on the benches like he's just got two
short person inventions like too small
like figurines
I mean elf is not what he's selling but
it's like the brand for Elf on a shelf
well tips it's funny to see Australia
once a christmas company they're both
seasonal and then he he'd invested in
some like panning for gold bucket what
it was cool but it's like it's it's a
bucket he runs like an online or like an
Internet security thing for something
like right yeah I don't know anyways if
you watched Shark Tank anyway you might
enjoy any of what we just said that's
not the podcast I still don't really
know what this podcast it thank you guys
we'll see you next week that is the
podcast not the podcast is I am gonna be
going into the shark tank and Jenna will
be the shark I have compiled I think 17
of my cream of the crop Julian
inventions so I was like snake oil but
without picking cards they just came
from your brain yeah it's pretty much
snake oil but we're gonna act like it's
something different no it's it's like
I'm Julian enters the shark tank
right like I have my inventions and you
have to decide if you want to invest in
them so you came up with 17 inventions
yeah roughly roughly give or take
give or take 17 so I might have zero
help us I don't I'm not ready for this
I'm not ready for this amount of Aires
all right first up in the tank it's
Julianne so Lomita who will be pitching
some history product and/or service to
the one and only shark Jenna who also is
completely unwilling to be here or
invest any money is here against her
will completely well you got hello
sharks
my name is Julian cotton is this when
they play that like uplifting tinkling
music I'm talking sorry cuz you're not
eating me yet I'm just trying to say do
you ever have a drink what I'm nervous
cuz you don't laugh at me
do you ever have a drink where you're
trying to sit through a straw but then
at the end of the drink you just get a
bunch of crunchy or a powder or coffee
grinds something at the bottom of the
cup that you don't want right yes it all
settles at the bottom or even sugar if
you drink coffee fast enough and you
pull off sugar in it just and then it's
like instant sugar but bad you ever do
that yeah pause well don't you wish you
could mix it around while also sipping
through this trial hold it right there
introducing scruff straw whisk it's a
straw with a tiny whisk it's a very tip
of it so that you can foam and even mix
things at the very bottom while also
sipping through the straw how are you
claiming that you can foam things with a
tiny whisk well if you whisk anything
hard enough it becomes foam so I'm not
the creator of science I'm just the
delivery I'm not really false I am NOT
the creator of science I am simply the
delivery man of it oh I'm delivering you
science in the form of a straw whisk you
the great descendant of Nikola Tesla
aren't you yes do you've any questions
about my invention yeah what's it made
out of metal the whole straws metal well
titanium and the whisk is plastic we
couldn't get a metal whisk oh it works
it works just don't put it in dishwasher
or wash it with hot water
so I can't put it in the dishwasher or
wash it with how lukewarm at best so how
am I gonna clean this just rinse it with
cold water what a fight drink something
really grainy or like let it soak
overnight maybe two nights to be safe
okay I have like a general rule for me
personally if it can't go in the washer
and dryer or in the dishwasher
I don't want it although I'm getting
word okay we can do metal whisks okay
thank you but it's gonna be a different
color than the other metal so you're
gonna see a difference in color from
metal to metal it's not going to be a
seamless design also do you want to know
if I have a patent no how much is each
straw and can you buy them in packs you
you can buy them in packs of one we only
sell them individually so just cool it
with trying to get a packs okay what if
I have like a restaurant or like a
coffee shop and you buy one at a time
like everybody else okay
the straw goes for $9.99 $9.99 excuse
you okay it cost us eight dollars and
fifty cents to make
we have horrible margins we need help I
don't know why it's so expensive to make
a strong risk do you have any sales um
well I gave one to my grandma but she
didn't pay me so I gave one away all
right Julian listen I think it's a it's
a cool idea I haven't seen anything like
it on the market also if you if you spin
the cup fast enough while you're holding
the straw whisk in your mouth you can
whisk without actually having a move
your face that's amazing
and I think you should keep going just
don't get it near your teeth
unfortunately are you sure yeah is there
anything I could do no just wait we have
a pen we got one when did you get a
patent just now did you file for one or
you just you just gave it to yourself I
drew one works what if I get a patent
tomorrow no I come back
you don't have any profit margin
whatsoever well we also don't have we're
not in the negative if I've only made
one
I need help manufacturing them lots
about manufacturing them it cost me
eight dollars to make at home by
yourself yeah okay are you sure
absolutely
okay
t-shirts are you gonna be Julian the
whole time or is that there other people
coming hello my name is Noah what's your
middle name
don't you expose me like that it's my
first name cuz I'm Noah no I'm gonna be
myself all the time
I'm Julian alright welcome to the tank
Julian thank you for welcoming me back
to the tank even though is my first time
here we talked about this before when
you're waking up in the morning and
you're choking down all those vitamins
and you think to yourself what the [ __ ]
am i doing to get all these vitamins I
have to choke down these huge horse
pills chunky chunky horse pills
in fact that's on our products there's
no more chunky chunky horse pills
whatever vitamin you are deficient in
because you're probably deficient in
lots of them
you don't you take them in the most
inefficient way you just choke down
these huge pills sometimes you'd gag and
that's the start of your day gagging I
can tell times on cows wouldn't you and
every every time you're throwing them
your throat and your sip in the water
you just you're just damn I wish I was
like eating french fries or something
well now you can get your vitamins when
you're eating your french fries with
vitamin ketchup oh yes you might have
heard about this as I've made
appearances outlets online vitamin
ketchup has all of the major vitamins A
through D D through P we don't have
we don't have iron in it we're working
on iron but every single vitamin I else
we have thousand percent of your daily
recommended so we took the daily
recommended and we said [ __ ] you and we
gave it ten times that okay in just one
little tablespoon of ketchup
it tastes nothing like ketchup it's red
it's creamy and it's just straight-up
vitamin it's we just crushed all the
vitamins and put red food dye
but you dip your ket you're you're
frying one little dollop of it and
you're just you know you're loaded with
vitamins okay why would you limit
yourself to catch up you want people to
eat french fries every day in order to
take their vitamins why would you need
to eat anything else
if you have character vitamin ketchup
you have all the vitamins in the world
what about like protein or just like
basic nutrition other than vitamins and
well our next our product next year or
if this does well we're gonna do protein
mustard but that's later yes we have to
sell at least like a couple thousand of
the vitamin ketchups to fund ourselves
there do you want to know how much it
costs well right now it's the first
bottle I made cost three hundred dollars
today cuz I had to go to like ten
different vitamin shops and buy them out
of almost everything so you crushed all
these vitamins up yourself with my hands
and put them into a paste that you are
calling ketchup yeah one of the vitamins
isn't is actually natural naturally
occurring in a tomato
so technically FDA said we can call
ketchup don't you can do it so you've
had contact with the FDA about this
product I looked on their website they
won't return my calls but I found other
QA on their website our frequently asked
questions what like what's in it I said
oh yeah well first of all I looked up
tomato that was the first step of my
quest and then once I found what was in
tomato I made sure that there was one
vitamin it's called vitamin T actually
weirdly it's natural and it's made of
vitamin T in our in our mixture then
what's what's the name of vitamin T
vitamin T just by doing
- yeah oh sorry um yeah vitamin T oh
okay anyway we're selling it in large
bottles like beer sized bottles for your
diners we sell only in bulk
you cannot just buy one so you know or
no I don't I don't want to eat vitamin
you're gonna be so vitamin
you're gonna be on it you're gonna be so
healthy you're not gonna want to eat
anything but fries and you're gonna feel
the best you've ever felt
that's just guaranteed you will reach
your fitness goals if you buy vitamin
ketchup guaranteed you can't do that
guaranteed you cannot do that guaranteed
if you don't reach your fitness goals
you lookin come find me I'll give you a
refund in person but you can't catch me
what does the vitamin pace have to do
with your fitness goals everything no
one's ever supplemented every single
vitamin out there in one item and shoved
it in your mouth what about a
multivitamin no that's what does your
vitamin is it is it multiple vitamins in
one vitamin vitamin shoppe aegean sea or
whatever in acquired all of these
vitamins up why wouldn't you just crush
up a multivitamin and put it in ketchup
well I don't I still don't know what
that is never heard of it from what I'm
getting I think it sounds like something
that has multiple vitamins in one pill
mm-hmm but this still doesn't solve the
problems for people who don't want to
take a pill what about they make
multivitamin gummies explores it -
gummies no you're not
yeah I'm allergic to gummies
Oh respect my allergies please Oh what
is it in the gummy you're allergic to
vitamin G okay you know what I'm out
please please I were to go my mom kicked
me out I stole her containers to use for
my ketchup I'm a mess in the kitchen I'm
really sorry that you never saw
multivitamins coming but okay
it was a good idea though Jillian I like
where you're going you unplugged your
headphone you don't need to turn around
every time you come back in the tank oh
my god my favorite episode of shark tank
was when they invested a night guys
YouTube gym it was really funny
okay I'm back I won't turn around
anymore that's kind of a mess
welcome I thank you for having me here
my name is Julian and I all right do you
use a mouse pad on my piece it's pretty
boring right they're all just the same
it's just one little piece of quarter
inch thick maybe rubber maybe rubber and
that's rubber
it's like foam foam stretchy foam but
they're all just the same they look
exactly the same every mouse pad in the
entire world is black I've never known
oh this balls I'm not done every single
mouse pad confirmed on earth has only
been made pure black with no designs on
them ever now it's time to juice up your
mouse pad game for all the people who
come over and look straight with that
mouse pad introducing Mouse plaid it's a
plaid mousepad that only comes in cloud
patterns
that's it that's it Julian it sounds
like you haven't done any research
whatsoever you've made your product
based off of a pun I'm out
wait you know any funds I don't like
puns but but now splat I'm so absolutely
out I'm sorry but good luck oh man I'm
so screwed okay okay okay I'm back I'm
back okay do you ever take something out
of you ever have a cold drink and you
want it to stay cold but by the bottom
sip it's just a little bit warm and
you're like [ __ ] and you just chuck it
at the wall because you just wish it was
cold and then you end up going to get
another one only to just loathe the
moment where you get bit back to that
low point and the drink and it's warm
again the drink doesn't stay cold it's
impossible
nothing exists for it to stay okay you
know introducing cold stir
it's a coaster that you put in the
freezer and then when you're ready to
drink you put it on your table and you
put your drink on it and it infuses cold
vibes into your drink so that when
you're at the bottom sip of your truth
it stays cold it stays cold cold vibes
is a scientific term cold vibe yeah so
basically they're coasters that you put
in the freezer they retain the cold
vibes and when you take them out they
put the cold into your drink has to be
warm ever again okay but we're also
developing a hot one you stick them in
the microwave if we're just doing a lot
of testing right now going through a lot
of microbes you just put it
we trying to cover both spectrums hot
and cold both sides of the spectrum
I'm telling you cold stir okay so the
offer is for a portion culture yeah but
ninety percent of my business not for
hot sir well if you invest in cold stir
okay both okay
you know since you didn't bring me any
samples today to use household not to
bring anything
the security guard took everything it
seems like just based on some logic that
it would just make at the bottom of your
drink
very cold that's the point there so it's
like the lower third of the liquid but
what about when you're drinking your
drink has ice cubes in it and you drink
it fast enough that you still have ice
cubes in it are those not keeping your
drink cold ice cubes why would you put
ice cubes in your drink that's just so
like I'm all about what about a hydro
flask or I'll get to that I have an
invention for that later so this is for
when you're at the table you're drinking
a cold glass of OJ with pulp and you
want the bottom houses you're not going
to put ice in your okay I'm talking
about drinks that like you don't Nate
you don't naturally put ice in it's like
weird it's not like a soda I'm talking
about like juice or juice or water I
don't think it's a bad idea just need to
know if it weren't same with your well
the coaster well the cold sirs are made
of glass so just drop them because they
will shatter if they're how is that
gonna stay cold well we tested a lot of
things and you it's like when you put a
frog in us were the only things we
tested what did not say cold glass
stayed cold it's like when you put a
glass in the freezer yes like a frosted
glass right that really doesn't say cold
that long well how long are you gonna
need finish your drink damn it you know
what um
it's not the worst idea I've ever heard
but I think that we're gonna run into
some issues
okay okay scrap scrap that hot sir
that's very hot sir I'm scrapping cold
sir hot sir sounds like it might be
dangerous hot sir I will even if it
kills someone on my team we are gonna do
all the testing we need to and all the
microwaves it's
make sure that whatever material we use
to put it in the microwave it definitely
works it definitely works have to be out
imagine I don't want a glass cold sir I
don't want a hot start medium stir a mug
what about a medium stir no it's not hot
enough I'm sorry but I'm out doing thank
you for coming are you
Sark's the whole time are you ever in a
meeting at work and you're you you just
you're chewing gum and you hate you
[ __ ] hate the meeting because you
hate your job but you're like it you're
chewing gum and you want to go to the
bathroom real quick
but you don't chew gum in the bathroom
because you know so where do you put
your gum while you go to the bathroom or
water break or something or you go
you're gonna go down the street to
Arby's you come back your your gum
--less introducing meeting gum
it's gum with plastic coating on the
outside so you can stick it under the
conference room table and come back to
it tomorrow or after your break without
having to worry about germs it's plastic
it's gonna be no plastic yeah it doesn't
doesn't trans I've tried it like three
times
no why why why deprive people of gum at
work they just wanna give them a little
bit of pleasure it's it's gum coated
with plastic no meeting gum you could be
the cool new guy in the office hey was
an email have some you're just like
chewing on a piece of plastic it stays
there for however long the best part
about the plastic filling aside from the
fact that it's pure plastic and it's
terrible for the environment is that it
will keep the gum fresh for as long as
you want in plastic how is it sticking
to things patent technology we had a
breakthrough
is it covered in
one of those little gummy hands that you
get out of like a little vending machine
like that kind of sticky I can't reveal
our formula on there is it sticky yes
so you're chewing a sticky substance in
your mouth that resembles gum that also
doesn't well we have flavors or flavors
do you want to know what flavors what
are your flavor when I love to do mint
we have the FDA said no for mint so we
found that the only food group that
would allow us to use their flavor is
bratwurst so we have bratwurst that's
disgusting
no you're chewing a bratwurst leave a
piece of plastic that you're then going
to stick under a conference tell me
that's not better than doing literally
nothing who wants to sit in a conference
room ever for any reason it sounds like
your target demo is a group of people
who aren't gonna be working in a
conference room very long so you're not
gonna have any customers what does that
mean because you can't just keep
sticking your gum and someone else's
table in a work environment but first of
all no one in the room owns the table
it's a rented lease of an office ok no
one's actually gonna lose it
second of all it's it's your board
Julian what innovative product not down
with the marketing I'm out
okay I'll come back from that one this
one was inspired by today's events today
we had a blackout our whole house lost
power for the entire day and part of the
night which reminded me I'm sitting
there with my lantern cranking away you
know just cranking away trying to give
that thing power because I knew that
later on in the night I have to pack my
bag and I have no light so I'm gonna
need some sort of light so I'm cranking
this is stupid
and then I farted and I thought to
myself imagine if I didn't have to do
any of the cranking to get this lantern
or energy into the lantern later you can
release the fart as energy as the form
of light your outside light out this is
literal light I'm giving you light in
the form of alternative energies inside
of your body it can't you want to hear
what the name of it is before you go out
please what
but lantern for emergencies when you
don't want to sit there and crank like a
troglodyte just put on the butt Lantern
every time you fart the butt lantern
transforms energy from your fart until
light and powers the lantern later on
I'm out why why yeah I'm just not
interested at all the people who are
prepped to survive in the event of
emergency with gas they're prepped with
gas I'm out what happens if you don't
have guests you need nothing besides gas
okay I'm so out you could oh I don't
want any gas related products there's a
filter it filters out the smell now
are you claiming that you're becoming
bioluminescent from farting or it goes
into the lanterns into the lantern and
now the buttpad it goes into your pants
right into right up right up against
your dumper it's like a filter it's like
you know when you've been created energy
to light a lantern oh please you're not
my scientist please I know what I'm
doing but you know it's like a dryer
sheet you put it in what's the energy
that it's feeding off of the heat that
is also very classified don't don't
don't ask that again actually don't even
ask that this is a lie it's not no it
doesn't understand my offer you can the
power alight with your fart I'm out
peace I'm out out I'm out I said I'm out
first I'm out good for you get out don't
come back [ __ ] okay ready mm-hmm
I have a company that helps people dress
the way they want ready are you ready
brace yourself yeah dress the way they
want without having to go to the store
it's like an online personal stylist
it's called stitch fix and what you do
is you sign up for stitch fix with a
profile of yourself just like you would
any other website but except for stitch
fix it's different in that you fill out
all sorts of different preferences about
what you like to wear do you wear
t-shirts do you wear hoodies do you wear
button-downs newer sweaters do you wear
ties
do you wear dresses do you wear blouses
how tight do you like them it's like so
down to every last detail that you could
ever think of it really does feel like
you have a personal stylist taking notes
on all of what you want in your wardrobe
so you basically log on a stitch fix
comm slash Evangeline tell them your
sizes tell them your preferences and you
basically get paired with your very own
personal assistant who hand picks items
to send right to your door then you try
them on and you pay only for what you
love and return the rest shipping
exchanges and returns are always free
and there's no subscription required you
can sign up to receive scheduled
shipments or get your fix from stitch
fix whenever you want their styling fee
is only $20 which is applied toward any
can you keep from your shipment you guys
can get started right now I actually
literally just filled out my stitch fix
profile I haven't got the clothes yet
because we just got it sorted but I'm
looking forward to getting my stylist to
send me clothes like what hello
that's super dope so go to stitch fix
comm slash annejulien get 25% off extra
when you keep all the items in your box
check it out stitch fix thank you also
guys honey book I know a lot of you guys
are graphic designers and photographers
out there and if you're trying to run
your own business based on that skill it
can be a pretty daunting thing to run a
business when all you really know how to
do or all you started knowing how to do
was just your craft basically honey book
is an all-in-one business platform for
small businesses they offer all sorts of
tools to streamline your workflow they
help you with calendar management custom
branding brochures proposals even
contracts which I know personally
firsthand that those can be a total
[ __ ] to get done so having a template
for those sorts of thing can go a very
very long way I started my own business
wofe circle it was like there's a lot of
things you don't see coming when you're
doing contracts and sending out things
to like brand X or any sort of a number
of things they help you with all sorts
of business focused parts of your your
venture and the payment is flexible you
can pay monthly or annually whichever
works for you best at the time and your
business honey books comm use code Jenna
Julian over seventy five thousand
photographers designers event
professionals and other solo
entrepreneurs have saved hundreds check
it out is a really cool service and I
think a lot of people here can get some
use out of it the link is in the
description also guys the skin okay if
you need to know what's going on in the
world don't jump from social media
social media or go to your home page or
get get uh what does it call when you go
to like New York Times they like lock
you out because you don't pay it's like
like some sort of wall okay well a
paywall don't get blocked by pay walls
the skin annoying the scheme is solving
all those problems for you the skin
takes information everywhere that they
get the most important little nuggets
that you need to know and they compile
it all in a like easy bite-size
beautiful news
into your email INBOX completely for
free every morning just go to the skin
th tsk IMM calm /n Julian you enter your
email you click Subscribe and then the
next day you're gonna get one in your
email how great is that
one of the things i do when i log on
like my phone in the morning is i go to
twitter moments just to see like what's
going on you know make sure there's like
no crazy events that you haven't seen
the skin does that for you they take the
top events that you need to know and
they tell you alright when you use that
URL the scheme home slash jenna julian
you were entered to win a $250 Visa gift
card
and that means you can spend it on
whatever you like so check it out hit
the link in the description and thank
you to our sponsors appreciate it
sponsors
[Music]
okay are you ready yeah Bobby do you
ever go out into the world whether it's
the gym or your office or the gym and
you're really thirsty but you don't
realize until you're out in the world
uh-huh do you I feel like you just said
that yeah sometimes I'm I'm away from
water and would like some water yeah
right yeah and do you ever like see
someone who has a hydro flat and you're
like that's what I want right now mm-hmm
that is a hydro flask and I wish it was
mine
yes introducing sorry you interrupted me
sorry I'm sorry go ahead
I thought sharks have manners
introducing my dro flask my jaw flask is
an online license that you illegally buy
from me to gives you legal ownership of
any hydroflax that you see out in the
world and want my truck lask
it's not a hydra flask it's my draw
flash really and this is another pun
company that is completely illegal and
does only $200 a month just PayPal me
please and now you will get your ID in
the mail at some point no and it'll have
your name completely spelled right I
promise I only [ __ ] up a couple don't
talk to those guys no thirst on the road
you're not gonna die of thirst you can
find somewhere that has all of what
water fountain that's pretty archaic to
me why not just grab a hydro class there
on every corner everyone has one and
they can all be yours they're not your
low low price of $200 to my PayPal every
month okay so if I need more if I use
your product and stole someone's Hydra
flask and got just slapped in the face
because I tried to steal someone else's
belonging what do you do for me then
well I'm gone by then I'm long gone I'm
out you don't also need to read the
small print no it's so small that by the
time you actually can read it I'm gone
I'm out and there is no print illegal
company don't report me I'm reporting
you don't report me I'm calling the cops
I'm starting a new company no it's
called my phone that's my phone no it's
my phone that's illegal I have a my
phone license I'm out criminal how are
you gonna run your business from jail
I'll figure out a way okay hello sharks
do you ever look into the mirror and
just think I wish there was more more
what just with the mirror like more
mirrors are boring they just look like
you do you ever think that
no okay introducing USB mirror is a
mirror with USB ports so when you plug
in your phone so you can plug in your
phone into it honestly I'm down
I'm absolutely down they probably exist
do they exist uh I have not checked
you should check no no no I'm here in
the shark tank I'm not gonna spend my
time with my phone I'm here pitching to
you do you have money for me no you plug
your phone into the mirror I understand
okay it would have been really helpful
at like in college I used to just have a
floor mirror and that was it so I would
sit in front of it and do my makeup well
I think a lot of people do things like
that like cuz it's the closest you can
get her if there's good light like a lot
of people sit on the ground against the
floor mirror to do their makeup or get
ready okay and just so we're clear you
just plug your phone into it yeah all
right are you into it
are you in exist no it doesn't exist I'm
the first person you look it up no I
refuse no no your phone that's rude it's
my investing no no no marbles how about
you are you interested sir you're
depressed I'll give you five dog bones
do you have any questions about the
products like what it's like don't look
stop please stop stop it stop it stop
stop no you didn't know can you listen
to my whole smart mere little intro
no like the one that I have in my
bathroom that has a can I explain that
my actual idea you didn't listen to what
it does you plug your phone into the
mirror so you don't lose your phone it
doesn't charge anything no no there's no
charging but that doesn't that means
that you're not gonna risk ever getting
shocked no no no plenty of mirrors
exists where you can plug your phone
into them if it's small there's a lot of
those that exist if it was a big floor
mirror maybe there's not too many but
know they exist Julian I'm sorry I have
to be out look that is a good idea okay
you ever put something velcro um sorry
I'm nervous let me start over hmm
do you ever put velcro stickies on
things to make them stick to each other
because well you need some velcro yeah
well introducing velcro no velcro no no
this is voice-activated velcro so it
sticks to itself when you say no it lets
go to the bond howdy boys activated
velcro no how did you harness the
technology from like saying an audible
word into it turning into a mechanical
action we stole it from who Siri Siri
doesn't do anything mechanical you can
just talk to her oh it works though I
don't know I paid a designer on Fiverr
and he made it he's an engineer it works
it works can you give me a scenario
where I'd like to say no what if I have
them holding different things that and
you say no just in conversation and they
all whichever one you're talking to
their releases it knows whichever one
you're talking to it now so just it just
knows maybe your you have your phone
velcro to the table just don't want it
to fall no the word is no not bulk no
well the products name is velcro no but
you say no if I say no in conversation
to you well my things everything will
fall it's just a sand you said it knows
which one I'm talking to
The Voice algorithm isn't quite there
yet oh and I doubt that exists okay fine
fine I'm on to the next one my real play
the theme song introducing my Fitness
enemy it's just like it's just like
MyFitnessPal but instead of tracking the
macros and calories for you once you
finish a meal it just tells you that you
should eat something else that's so
negative absolutely not imagine
finishing a giant bowl of pasta and then
your pick up your phone open my fitness
any means as should a pizza idiot no
negative no I'm out or if you're just
chomping on some celery and your Fitness
enemy pops up it's gonna load I push
notification that says how about that
taco truck idiot you should add talk I'm
out fine I don't know what anything
negative telling me what to send you the
app for free don't worry about it
introducing do do you ever take a nap
and feel bad for doing it yeah you do
that's the thing right nap guilt yeah
over 50,000 million Americans suffer
every year from nap guilt
but no more introducing grandma pillow
with grandma pillow you upload a
recording of your grandma saying good
job name you deserve a nap so when you
lay your head down on the pillow that's
what you hear guilty naps no more if
your grandma's dead we have stock
grandma recordings that you can use oh
my god all my grandparents are dead well
we have sock recordings it's a common
thing for people's grandparents to be
dead so why does the recording of your
grandma saying good job you deserve a
nap who doesn't want to get complimented
by their grandma so oh so it's
encouraging you to take the knife yes
and feel good about yes itself it's all
about self-love unlike my Fitness enemy
it's quite the opposite of mine Fitness
enemy actually a pillow pal I want to
rename it can I rename it that's a thing
that exists no or my pillow pillow
powers mine no no it's grandma pillow
grandma pillow pal I like the idea
holy [ __ ] this is the talking
yeah well it's a talking pillow that you
can upload mp3s directly to the US
it for you so you can't do it once you
buy the pillow it's stuck with that
noise mm-hmm
we're talking we're in talk to the
build-a-bear they said no but we're
still in talks for that we go stop
emailing them no come on
grandma thora it's why would I need to
buy a pillow when I could just listen to
a recording of my grandma saying good
job Jenna you deserve a nap
where someone's grandma was just like a
grandma voice okay why don't I just
listen to that why do we need to buy
your pillow because it's a pillow who
the hell doesn't need a new pillow I do
I've seen the pillows I don't need a new
pillow I've seen your pillows you could
use a new one I like my pillows I just
how about like five bucks cash alright u
ever browsing SoundCloud and then look
up from the screen and think what the
[ __ ] am i doing with my life
Wow Julianne what yeah sure SoundCloud
is one thing sound why would you spend
so much time on one thing it's one sense
only one of your senses gets to
appreciate it you're depriving the rest
of your body of what is this my legs but
then he just like set down so he likes
the cool table mm-hmm why would you
deprive your whole body of all the other
senses out there in the world
introducing and also there's different
types of artists out there ones that
don't make sounds mm-hmm introducing
smell cloud it's for you artists out
there who could make art in the form of
smell now like SoundCloud but for your
nose no drugs allowed you plug the smell
of cloud chip into your nose and then
download the app not on Android and you
can scroll through your feet of smells
that artist in the UK is coming to the
US soon have uploaded honestly
interesting that technology doesn't
exist it's like how people always wanted
smellivision okay but you have to just
because it rhymes with television work
with me a little bit smell cloud yeah it
sounds good right cloud I think that
there's definitely a market for people
that love smells people love and if some
guy just tries to run it all by
uploading farts he gets he gets strikes
on his account
there's plenty people that would love to
to digitally go through a file of smells
like if someone could recreate the smell
of my garage when I was young like I
would pay anything it was the best smell
in the whole world I made of that smell
it was like a mixture of like our
lawnmower gasoline with like this like
nothing it was so good it was like musty
mossy smell like it was just incredible
I loved it I would go in there just to
smell it okay like smells are really
powerful but you can't yeah I doubt that
your technology exists that you can move
it in here no just roll with it a little
bit it exists
okay invest in something I'll invest in
that smell cloud yeah all right 50/50
high still 100% of it though all effects
you thank you all right next up I got
showed you like two more sure
paperweight spell w AIT it's a
paperweight that says weight on it no no
no that can provide physical weight nope
but also serve as a scientific earns
patients in life
paperweight that's a novelty pun I'm out
all of these are puns okay our alarm
clock are you armed clock it's an alarm
clock that goes off anytime ariana
grande releases new music but the sound
isn't ariana music it's do we all we
could get with [ __ ] music how much
fifty five dollars per unit then all the
way em I wanna buy 40% of the company
you know you through me yes for sure you
threw me for a loop there when you said
you couldn't get Ariana's music pony
said Chingy like I'm sold
yeah so it does alert the algorithm does
work everytime she drops new music on
any platform it goes off but the music
that it goes off with is ching-he music
I'm down I'm down he let us use his
music absolutely love it I love that as
long as you're cool ariana not making a
cent off of this that's fine it's all
goes to me and yeah you definitely are
alarm clock our alarm clock very excited
don't scratch my finger when we shake
hands okay Liam one more note
okay just as 2d printer thing is just a
printer
do you wanna invest Oh 2d printer yeah
with like paper yeah no I'm out if
you're looking at printers and you see
old boring whatever printer LaserJet
Judy printer you're gonna buy the 2d
printer no I'm not it's telling you how
many dimensions it works on I'm
literally not 2d printer no 5d like
ridges a little picture what what
defines two point five DS almost no 3rd
dimension it's not quite in the 2nd
dimension it's 2.5 inches legal unique
topographical maps with it I think that
that's 3d it's 2.5 so it's 2.5 because
it's like raised a little but it's not
quite a physical object it's still paper
just raised I skip its class in high
school I don't know any of this I'm out
ok that's fair I wouldn't invest either
2d printer I'm out
I'll get investors elsewhere I got some
guys down on the club who would do this
hey guys so far the only companies I
invested in were smell cloud and re
alarm clock yes okay well you know what
I can only come up with so many
inventions I worked about a week on this
list okay I really worked on this list
not the whole week consecutively like a
couple moments throughout the week but I
did I where I'm try to make these good
invention sled Mouse plan get rid of
your boring ass mouse pads well I don't
know how did I do in the shark tank it
was good you have a lot of creative
products some of them definitely don't
or can't exist vitamin catch another
example it's not ketchup and sounds
disgusting but other than that I mean no
knock until you try really really good
creativity in your products and I will
buy a mirror with the USB in it that
sounds nice okay it doesn't charge your
phone at all it's just
basically to make mein so you don't lose
your phone bait is a glorified rope I'll
just put my phone on a rope if I feel
like I'm gonna lose this rope charger
rope USB it's a USB that you plug into
your phone and instead of charging your
phone it sticks out little spikes inside
your phone and locks in so no matter
what you do you cannot take it out of
your phone and that would cause problems
ok no more of this song well thank you
guys for joining us it was really good
to him Thank You Shane you're watching
shark shark tank Julianne edition yeah
what could we don't know Julian Julian
tries to sell inventions on shark tank
[Music]
Julian goes into the shark tank maybe
Julian in the shark tank well so cute
thank you guys for hanging out this for
another episode we love you all very
much and we hope you have a wonderful
week we'll see you guys next week for
another podcast good luck in Canada
Julie thank you by this time for you
guys I will be back hopefully the trip
went well and we got into the country
you guys be good we'll see you in a week
[Music]
[Music]